[Music]
it is a story that we've been following
for several weeks now homeless
encampments along the flamingo Arroyo
Trail at last check the county was going
to step up enforcement in the area
stating that by this week a portion of
the bridge and Trail would be cleared
out Madison Kimbrough has been following
this story and brings us the latest
a week ago you couldn't even walk or
ride your bike on this Trail without
bumping into homeless encampments but
today there's finally light at the end
of the bridge I used to utilize those
bridges you know my husband and I would
take our dogs for walks across them so
it's a good thing that they're moving
them off if they can keep them off
that would be wonderful Kathy who works
in the area is beyond pleased at this
portion of the flamingo Arroyo Trail has
finally been cleared located on Desert
Inn and Mojave Kathy and nearby
residents tired of not feeling
comfortable in their own neighborhood
it's not good when we have clients
coming up and they're sitting on the
sidewalk there is drug dealing going on
with them as well I just feel for the
people I feel for them sometimes I do
need a break though you know I do want
to be able to walk my son across the
bridge and take a view and take a look
you know what I'm saying and not feel
for my safety County Commissioner tick
sagerbloom listening to those pleased
for Help by community members on
Wednesday Metro and other County
officials made their move giving those
on the bridge and Trail notice that they
would need to move their belongings if
one guy had about 50 bikes we said You
know here you can take your time to get
the bikes out of there which which we
allowed to do the key is is this
monitoring on a daily basis so we don't
just move the other house and then have
them come back and while cleaning this
portion of the trail is a start Sega
Bloom acknowledges the fact that it's
not fixing the root of the issue the
problem is we're not really securing the
homeless problem we're just moving the
homeless problem and so going forward we
need to figure out a way to actually
have places where people can move and
while this portion of the trail is
cleared out now those around are
skeptical at how long it will last
reporting near Desert Inn and Mojave
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now